it's like in my office yeah Will Ferrell
an anchorman many people can't squeeze
of work out into their workday in
today's warning rounds one doctor says a
nine minute workout could be the
prescription to building a stronger
healthier body researchers at Penn State
say older Americans who strength pain
train just twice a week have a 46% lower
risk of death than those who don't
regular exercise can prevent heart
disease diabetes and even some cancers
dr. Jordan metals nine-minute strength
workout is on the New York Times website
today he's a sports physician at New
York's Hospital for Special Surgery
welcome back morning great day what can
you actually accomplish in nine minutes
so people think like nine minutes you
know what can I do in nine minutes and
the answer is you can do a ton in nine
minutes so this is all about what's
called a high-intensity interval
training and that is to basically take a
one minute at a time workout maximum
intensity and that translates into much
bigger gains in fact we think that the
gains from intense workouts are in some
ways better than the gains you get from
longer whi more steady workout like that
but we've looked at it both from things
like strength acquisition but also
metabolism things like burning
carbohydrates and it's interesting
there's been a couple research studies
that have come out in the past couple
months looking on a cellular level this
seems to slow cellular aging so the
Fountain of Youth may be in intensity
and getting people to really be
aggressive and we have people doing
these kind of workouts up into their 70s
in their age I like the nine minutes but
why do you have to have a Burpee in that
I hate those they'll you hate the verb
every time you come here you yeah the
Burpee I'm configured do you think
that's why I don't know I just don't
like it but maybe you were onto
something but I therapies will get I
mean the Burpee is the way that jumping
up and down I'm so out of breath so let
me have the Burpee city in in our
workout what we try and do is to give
different types in workout get a nice
video the Burpee on TV see this person
they're looking very happy and in this
workout you can have he looks thrilled
and basically we have demonstrations of
how people can do these at home just
like you can do and the reason this is
so efficient is that you're working all
of your muscles at once in our workout
we have basically no weights at all it's
using your body weight to learn how to
do these kind of exercises and people
think you know I need to go to the gym
and I
need an hour yeah disability roll out of
bed and 9 or 10 idea is to do this every
day to do this every other day what side
let's do it so this is part of what you
do this every single day alone is
probably not enough the American College
of Sports Medicine recommends about 150
minutes of exercise a week which is
about 30 minutes a day yeah but this
seems to double so if you do like 9
minutes the equivalents about a
two-to-one ratio so that's about 20
minutes of regular exercise so the idea
is to do this maybe a couple of three
days a week yeah and then do whatever
else you like to do on the other days I
know in your practice you treat a lot of
sports injuries so how can this strength
training prevent injury well that's a
lot of what I do I want my patients to
move and to be active for their entire
lives and so strength training is so
important for if you have arthritis in
your knees or an achy back or an achy
shoulder and I have patients of all ages
kids to grandparents doing these kind of
strength exercises and the goal of all
the projects I've worked on this thing
with in New York Times our book on
sports medicine the workout prescription
of how to do strength training at home
all of these things are ways to teach
people how to do strength training at
home and do it on their own without
going to the gym you don't need a big
space - yeah that's the key thing
Jordi's dr. jordan Metzl thanks very
much